also breaking tonight growing questions
about dr anthony fauci's
conduct regarding those emails and
concerning the debate over the
origins of the coronavirus his critics
say his positions have been
inconsistent at best deceptive at worst
but he continues to have the full
support
publicly at least from the president
white house correspondent peter ducey
has details tonight live from the north
lawn good evening peter
good evening brett president biden
campaigned on a promise
to hire dr fauci and fire donald trump
but now there are new questions about
what kind of council fauci was giving
the former president
as there are new calls for him to be
fired
i mean how many more times does this guy
need to lie before
he's ousted this is senator marco
rubio's problem
fauci has repeatedly demonstrated a
history of moving goal posts when it
comes to public health withholding facts
that don't conform
with his own narrative and issuing
inappropriate personal judgments that
distort the truth
but for now fauci's job is safe
just since you mentioned dr thaucci
again can you imagine any circumstance
where president biden would ever fire
him
no fauci's inbox early in the pandemic
contained word that it's possible covet
19 was not natural but engineered
although experts don't think that means
fauci had bad intentions
early on the email that's being focused
on is a so-called smoking gun if you
will is an email tony received
from some really good scientists
suggesting that they felt this could
have been an engineered pathogen early
on
two experts now write in the wall street
journal the scientific evidence points
to the conclusion that the virus was
developed in a laboratory
but the chinese are withholding critical
data from the world health organization
so there's a reason why after a plane
crashes we do everything possible to
understand
what happened if we're not if we don't
learn those lessons there are other
planes that are in the air
for all we know the next pandemic is
just around the corner
the white house has been diplomatic
about the lack of cooperation so far
i have personally and we collectively
have been quite vocal about our view
that there needs to be a second round to
this investigation that truly gets
to the heart of the matter which is the
original data and original information
that is still being withheld by china
and our hope is that in the coming
months we will
see a credible international
investigation progress
uh including in respect to those items
but that
might be tough china has basically
already said they think their part
in an international investigation is
done so why is jake sullivan still here
saying he thinks it's
possible that they're going to provide
the preliminary
data well i don't think we just give up
that easily
uh we are can continue to press in
coordination with the international
community
just outside the door to the west wing
right now the secretary general of nato
is holding court with reporters after a
long
meeting with president biden we didn't
see president biden on camera
at all today he did send his top
diplomat the secretary of state anthony
blinken to capitol hill though and
to testify in front of congress i should
say and while he was doing that lincoln
said he cannot put a percentage
on the likelihood that kovat may have
leaked out of a lab in china
brett you know peter a bit of a stir uh
the president biden or the white house
did not put out a statement a tweet or a
post
commemorating d-day yes yeah and brett
when i asked an official here about that
they directed me to the president's
remarks last week on memorial day where
he did mention the beaches of normandy
while
commemorating memorial day but i did not
get a clear answer
from or a clear explanation from jen
saki when i asked her
why it is that presidents bush obama and
trump
all commemorated d-day on d-day but
biden
didn't and she says the d-day is
something the president has talked a lot
about and we may hear more about
in coming days right okay peter ducey
live on the north lawn peter thanks